glean maxwell was found guilty of
charges tied to jeffrey epstein's sex
trafficking ring a new york jury
convicted the british socialite of
grooming minors for sexual abuse at the
hands of epstein it was hard to see if
she was showing any real emotion because
there was a mask over her face but i can
tell you within moments of hearing
guilty on count one not guilty on count
two and guilty on those other four
counts she sort of took a deep breath
and
looked as though she was pouring herself
some water the charges stemmed from
interactions ranging from 1994 to 2004.
maxwell was romantically involved and
later worked for epstein during that
time the prosecution argued that maxwell
was epstein's partner in crime and
critical to his alleged sex trafficking
operation throughout the two-week trial
jurors heard from four alleged victims
who claimed maxwell recruited them for
epstein and that she normalized and
sometimes even participated in the abuse
epstein committed suicide in august 2019
while awaiting trial
following the verdict u.s attorney
damien williams read in a statement in
part quote i want to commend the bravery
of the girls now grown women who stepped
out of the shadows and into the
courtroom their courage and willingness
to face their abuser made this case in
today's result possible again this is a
big day for a number of women not just
the four that with the center of this
trial but the dozens of women who
accused jeffrey epstein of sexual abuse
and never got to see his case go to
trial
maxwell was found guilty of five of the
six federal counts and she now faces a
maximum sentence of 65 years in prison
it's absolutely a repudiation of the
defense's tactic here the defense
frankly i think trying to blame the
victims saying their memories were
faulty saying that they were really
motivated by money her attorney has
announced plans to appeal the verdict so
in this case the guilt phase obviously
is over at least on the trial court
level and the next phase will be
sentencing so the prosecution will come
forward with a sentencing memo the
defense will say well look we think
there's some mitigating factors here but
let's be honest glenn maxwell faces
years if not decades in federal prison